[Music]
on this Thursday night Winnipeg's police
chief pressured to step down the
backlash to the decision not to search a
landfill for murdered indigenous women
the message you are sending is that
indigenous
women don't matter
Alberta's sovereignty act passes it's
not like Ottawa is a national government
what's been removed from it and why the
debate about its overreach is still
raging
finally free the prisoner swap that led
to the release of U.S basketball star
Brittany Greiner from a Russian prison
plus the Canadian geoscientist who
helped unearth the planet's oldest DNA
in Greenland the doors this could open
National with Donna Friesen good evening
and thanks for joining us we begin with
a search for three murdered indigenous
women in Winnipeg the province has asked
The Operators of a private landfill site
to pause operations the Prairie green
landfill north of Winnipeg is where
police suspect the remains of two of the
murdered women are located their
families along with indigenous leaders
in Manitoba have been calling on
Winnipeg's police chief to resign
because the force has said searching
that site was not feasible
and here you are once again creating
unmarked Graves of indigenous peoples
that's wrong how dare you tell us that
you cannot find our missing woman
today the federal minister of crown
indigenous relations said the women's
families deserve the answers they are
looking for
nobody should have to go through this
pain and through the re-traumatizing
process to uncover the truth and get to
Justice
nobody should have to search for their
mother in the trash and no human
should be treated like trash
Melissa ridgeen has our top story
tonight from Winnipeg not only have you
refused to search these landfills you
have presented no alternative routes for
how we can give these women peace that's
Kira Harris one of the daughters of
victim Morgan Harris calling for
Winnipeg police chief Danny Smythe to
step down for his Department's decision
to not recover bodies of indigenous
women believed murdered by an alleged
serial killer and dumped in a landfill
last Spring Police forensics inspector
cam McKidd said more than a month passed
when police believe the three victims
remains ended up in the landfill and
when police learned of it in that time
they say nine thousand tons of heavy
construction mud 1500 tons of animal
remains and 250 tons of asbestos were
dumped there while heavy construction
equipment packed it all down police
estimate the remains of Morgan Harris
Mercedes Myron and an unidentified woman
the elders have named Buffalo Woman are
somewhere in a Four Acre area under at
least 40 feet of densely compacted waste
our intent from from day one from minute
one is to conduct a search
there are times and this I believe is
one of them where a search just simply
wasn't feasible for the reasons I've
described today but the million dollar
question is would police at least try to
find these women if they weren't
indigenous and then do they have a
responsibility if they believe they're
in the landfill to recover them and to
return them to their families the
message you you are sending to the
Greater Community to the non-indigenous
community is that
indigenous
women don't matter
that if somebody wants to Target and
hurt our women
that they can dump them in the landfill
and no one will look for them
comparisons have been made to the Picton
Farm in Port Coquitlam BC where forensic
teams spent nearly two years scouring a
much larger 6.5 hectare area for remains
of murdered women Premier Heather
Stephenson and Mayor Scott Gillingham
held a press conference late in the day
to announce that operations at the
landfill are going to stop while they
determine next steps today's about about
the premier and I coming together the
city and the province coming together to
try to recognize the need that families
have Smite hasn't responded to demands
for his resignation or requests for
comment 35 year old Jeremy skebicki is
in custody facing first-degree murder
charges in the death of the three women
as well as 24 year old Rebecca cantwa
his lawyer says he will plead not guilty
how he knew the women has not been made
public Melissa Ridge in Global News
Winnipeg
Alberta's United conservative party has
quickly passed its controversial
sovereignty act though it removed a
provision that would have granted
extraordinary powers to the cabinet of
Premier Danielle Smith she describes the
bill as resetting the relationship with
the Prime Minister and the federal
government indigenous leaders say they
were not consulted and they've called
for it to be scrapped
it is infringing upon our rights and we
will not
stand idly by we will not allow it to
happen this is a warning to Canadians if
you care about these lands if you care
about your country
the bill could allow Alberta to ignore
treaty rights and federal laws Eric
Sorensen reports on the debate
continuing to rage over the sovereignty
Act and the intentions of Alberta's
premier
Mr Speaker with a conservative majority
in the Alberta legislature the
sovereignty Act passed easily motion is
carried
care sweeping powers for cabinet were
stripped out but the ACT means the
province will try to override any
federal law from Ottawa that the
province believes harms Alberta and
Premier Danielle Smith says she'll have
the Constitutional authority to do so
it's not like Ottawa is a national
government as the way our country works
is that we are a Federation of sovereign
independent jurisdictions they are one
in of those signatories to the
Constitution and the the rest of us are
signatories to the Constitution have a
right to exercise our sovereign powers
and our own area of jurisdiction Alberta
could for example deem Federal
Environmental legislation as harmful to
Alberta's oil economy the Prime Minister
sees a divisive political move and for
now he's not biting the sovereignty act
in Alberta is being moved forward
as very much a political tool to try and
pick a fight with the federal government
and I'm not interested in fighting
with the Alberta Government indigenous
leaders see the Alberta act and a new
law in Saskatchewan over natural
resources as a threat to their inherent
rights when legislation like this comes
forward the sovereignty act the SAS
First Act and without consulting First
Nations first that's just
disrespectful
and we are tired of being disrespected
at some point Ottawa will have to reckon
with the growing push for more
provincial powers in laws like the
sovereignty act the rest of Canada
should should watch carefully to see
what the government does with this bill
now because this is really starting to
Define what it mean what what federalism
really means in Canada on the day that
her portrait was unveiled as former
Premier Rachel notley promised to repeal
the ACT if she's re-elected so the first
real battle could be fought not with
Ottawa but within Alberta the outcome of
a provincial election next spring could
give momentum to the sovereignty act or
kill it Eric Sorensen Global News
the federal government is taking steps
that it says are aimed at strengthening
child care in this country the family's
Minister Karina Gould introduced bill
c-35 today if passed it would enshrine
the principles of a national Child Care
System into federal law that could help
make it harder to change or cut should
another party take power Mackenzie gray
is looking into this for us Mackenzie
Donna the Liberals are trying to make
their daycare plan Pierre pauliev proof
attempting to Brand it as politically
poisonous to kill one of their signature
social programs this cements our vision
of child care and I would say Canadians
vision of child care that Vision now
includes legislation and commitments to
long-term funding for child care but
Bill c-35 doesn't back that promise up
with new money or set any national
standards that's left to the 13
individual deals the feds cut with
provinces and territories deals Karina
Gould believes would be difficult for
future governments to walk away from
conservatives wouldn't be able to hide
this they would have to very publicly
tell Canadians that they do not believe
in affordable child care they will not
be supporting families and they will not
be building a system it's happened
before Stephen Harper canceled Child
Care agreements Paul Martin struck with
the provinces opting for tax credits
instead current conservatives aren't
committing to taking the Harper approach
but do want the Liberals to make some
changes the current approach isn't
working for example in the province of
Alberta
seven percent of operators can't access
the funding I
care for parents like Atlanta Powell the
biggest issue is finding a child care
spot her maternity leave is ending in
February with her daughter Penelope
still on a daycare waiting list to
imagine that Penelope is just gonna have
to be at home watching mummy work or you
know spending time in front of screens
it's just going to be really challenging
to try and balance her needs and do my
job full time the legislation is also a
key element of the supply and confidence
agreement that Justin Trudeau and jug
meet Singh struck the NDP sang they'll
support the bill Donna applauding the
Liberals for focusing their plan on
not-for-profit Spaces
okay Mackenzie and Ottawa thanks the
RCMP has suspended a procurement
contract with an ontario-based company
that has ties to China because of
concerns about National Security the
half million dollar contract was awarded
to Sinclair Technologies to supply radio
frequency equipment to the RCMP
Sinclair's parent company is controlled
by the Chinese firm hyterra which the
Chinese government has a 10 percent
stake in itera faces Espionage charges
in the U.S the government says other
contracts given to Sinclair will be
reviewed
after months of high-level negotiations
between Moscow and Washington American
basketball star Brittany Greiner is
headed back to the U.S the American
Olympian was arrested in February on
drug charges that led to a campaign by
her family teammates and celebrities to
bring her home for a nassera has more on
the prisoner's swap that made it happen
[Music]
you fly back home to the uh
WNBA star Brittany Greiner on a plane
heading for the United States after
being detained in Russia for the past
nine months but her release comes at a
price in one of the most high-profile
prisoner swaps between the two countries
since the Cold War happening at this
mutually agreed upon location in Abu
Dhabi Greiner arrested at the airport
last time she was heading home for
having less than a gram of cannabis oil
in exchange for notorious Russian arms
dealer Victor bout known as The Merchant
of death who was serving a 25-year
sentence for conspiring to kill
Americans by selling weapons to
terrorists this is a day we've worked
toward for a long time greiner's wife
and President Joe Biden broke the news
to the two-time Olympic gold medalist
this morning over the last nine months
you all have been
um
so privy to one of the darkest moments
of my life and so today I'm just
standing here overwhelmed with the
emotions questions remain regarding what
the White House is doing about the other
Americans still in Russian custody
canadian-born Paul Whelan a former
Marine businessman was in Moscow
attending a friend's wedding in 2018
when he was detained by Russian
intelligence accused of being a spy a
charge the U.S denies sadly for totally
illegitimate reasons Russia is treating
Paul's case differently than Britney's
we villain spoke with CNN after learning
if griner's release saying he was
disappointed not to be part of the deal
regardless of the price they might have
to pay at this point this was not a
choice of which American to bring home
the choice was one
or none unlike Griner who will be home
for the holidays Whelan's family worries
he won't be able to survive Another Year
in Russian custody Farah Nasser Global
News Washington
to Saudi Arabia now Crown Prince
Mohammed bin Salman has welcomed China's
president for an official visit Xi
Jinping was greeted by Jets cannons and
Cavalry his three-day diplomatic visit
is intended to strengthen ties between
Beijing and Riyadh two leaders signed a
partnership agreement as well as
multiple deals on trade technology and
energy with more expected in the coming
days
in the U.S Congress has passed Landmark
legislation to protect same-sex and
interracial marriage the motion is
adopted
the respect for Marriage Act got through
both Chambers with enough Republican
support for it to pass it codifies
Federal Protection for same-sex and
interracial marriage support for the ACT
gained momentum after the Supreme Court
overturned Roe versus Wade in June there
were fears the court could take aim at
same-sex marriage according to the
latest Census Data there are more than
1.2 million same-sex households in the
U.S
automation Nation coming up the rising
Road robots play in our food supply
chain
Automation and artificial intelligence
play a role in nearly every facet of Our
Lives including the production of the
food we eat over the years they become
integral to how products get from the
farm to our dinner table in part two of
our automation Nation series and gabiola
looks at how robots are taking on jobs
humans can't or won't do
getting to the root of soaring food
inflation includes a close look at what
it takes to produce what we eat it's
becoming more and more difficult for us
to have large labor forces that are
willing to stand at a 30 degree field
and pull weeds out of the ground
robotics is just a necessary Next Step
nearly three quarters of agribusinesses
in Canada are short staffed Nexus
robotics founder tarek greenen who's
developing a self-driving weed pulling
robot says machines are the solution if
we want to have food that's reasonably
priced we need these Farms to continue
to have great yields and we need these
jobs to be done robots are involved in
every part of the food supply chain
starting with agriculture for harvesting
and monitoring crops livestock farmers
are using robotics to feed milk manage
and clean animals during processing raw
food is cleaned sorted cooked or baked
packaged and transported and Robotics
and automation are already well
integrated into the warehousing stage
Loblaw recently launched its Fleet of
semi-autonomous delivery trucks no human
in the driver's seat though there is a
safety pilot on standby on the passenger
side this is a partnership with Silicon
Valley company gatic whose goal is to
move to a remote driver model so we have
today five trucks operating back and
forth on these routes typically
operating 12 hours daily seven days a
week the companies touted a clean safety
record after two years logging more than
150 000 deliveries these temperature
controlled trucks are already being used
by Walmart in the U.S but Loblaw is a
Canadian first pandemic supply chain
challenges have accelerated the adoption
of automation minimizing human handling
of food is valued now more than ever and
so is reliability
we're only starting to understand the
impact of this shift on the labor market
and the number of jobs lost and this may
make a dent in food inflation but taste
and service won't be the same without
the human touch and gaviola Global News
Toronto
DNA Discovery ahead the two million year
old ecosystem discovered in Greenland
[Music]
there has been a huge breakthrough in
DNA research with a connection to a
Canadian University Nova scotia's
Dalhousie University is part of an
international research team being
credited with discovering the world's
oldest DNA samples they were uncovered
in Greenland and as Ross Lord reports
they give us a glimpse at Life 2 million
years ago for scientist John Goss
contributing to a big advancement in DNA
research is a career highlight at his
laboratory in Dalhousie University Goss
analyzed Isotopes from quartz collected
in Northern Greenland concluding it's
about 2 million years old his work
helped in international research team
conclude DNA they extracted from nearby
Clay is the same age we just have been
so limited to you know really the last
one million years that was the oldest
until this study and now we think we
open up the doors to much older the DNA
collected by the team is also revealing
they sequence some animals that we
didn't expect to be there and one was
the American mastodon and until this
study it was really limited to parts of
North America how the Mastodon got to
Northern Greenland is among many new
questions arising from Gaining access to
a million more years of evidence I don't
know what ancest industry.ca is going to
do with all this new data but you know
we'll be able to push back our knowledge
about our our entire ancestry the
possibilities he says are endless how
far back can we trace the human genome
and and what was the pattern the real
pattern of migration we've we've got
ideas based on a limited number of bones
and other artifacts that we have but can
we really improve that next up delving
deeper into artifacts that are even more
mind-bending this is a four million year
old tree stump and yeah it feels like
any other and looks like any other tree
or tree stump right yeah wow the stomp
is from Ellesmere Island in Canada's
High Arctic Goss hopes to join DNA
experts on an expedition there in the
new year to collect new samples from a
long long time ago
Ross Lord Global News Halifax
well
relations next
Harry and Megan's Show on Netflix
[Music]
Canadian singer Celine Dion has
postponed her tour dates and revealed
she has a rare incurable neurological
disorder it's called stiff person
syndrome
have been dealing with problems with my
health for a long time
and it's been really difficult for me to
face these challenges
and to talk about everything that I've
been going through
stiff person syndrome makes her muscles
spasm uncontrollably and has made it
difficult for her to walk and sing Dion
says she has a team of doctors working
with her the disorder can be treated to
slow its progression the 20-time Juno
award-winning artist postponed the
spring portion of her upcoming tour to
2024 and she's canceled eight shows
slated for this summer
Prince Harry and Megan's series on
Netflix is out the first three episodes
of a highly anticipated series about
their story and their rocky relationship
with the royal family it's supposed to
be a tell-all that promises the truth
but some see it as a self-serving
reality show Crystal gemancing Reports
on the reaction
there's a new Feeding Frenzy for Royal
Watchers
the hierarchy of the family you know
there's leaking but there's also
planting of stories I feel they're just
doing it for money and so no I I I don't
agree with them I think at the moment I
think Harry needs some men Broken
Bridges with his family Harry and Megan
didn't include any Bombshells at least
not in the first three available
episodes but the Netflix documentary did
get people talking there was a war
against Megan to suit other people's
agendas the successful American actress
quickly became the bad guy in what
started as a widely loved love story
it's just an era of racism to it it's
just uh
you don't get the same level of scrutiny
for other members of your households I
just do think it's
Harry talks about his earliest memories
or of being swarmed by Paparazzi the
family baggage he brings to
relationships and how they both
sacrificed everything to join the
other's world
it was in February 2021 when Buckingham
Palace announced the couple would be
leaving active Royal life
the king however had a full day of work
I'm sure there has been a lot that's
gone wrong but there is in every family
and you just shut up and Talk Amongst
yourselves you don't air it to the World
the documentary won't be everyone's cup
of tea but it does play on what the
tabloids have been dining out on for
decades
Crystal gemancing Global News
[Music]
and that is global national for this
Thursday I'm Donna freeze and tonight's
Euro Canada is White Horse Santa driving
a truck lit up for the holidays we'd
love to see your festive Canada photos
please email them to viewers at
globalnational.com thanks for watching
Jeff Semple will be at the anchor desk
tomorrow and I'll see you Saturday for
the new reality bye-bye
[Music]